someone wants to come in Manhattan Beach
I tell them that they need to be patient
the real estate market Manhattan Beach
is absolutely on fire but there is no
inventory I've been a developer in
Manhattan Beach for 19 years in the past
and the hottest markets that I've ever
seen we would have roughly 240 homes
available currently we're running at
roughly 40 homes on the market we're
very very scarce there is a property
that just came on the market last week 4
million 450 as a teardown it's only
1,300 square foot lot it now has 34
offers on that beach has four distinct
areas right along the beach is an area
called the Strand and that's the
oceanfront properties and those
properties are through the roof right
now in terms of values
this property right here just sold for
16 million dollars that equates to about
4,000 a square foot just for the land
value alone this property is obviously a
teardown human half beach we have some
of the biggest hedge fund managers a lot
of X Facebook people Vince Vaughn
recently bought a house the Jimmy Kimmel
has a house in town as well virtually
the entire Los Angeles Kings hockey team
they prefer to live here because of the
lifestyle versus Beverly Hills where
it's very flashy and fancy here in town
it's more about family it's just got a
real sense of community it's kind of
like a micro economy in itself
completely different and unaffected than
a lot of the other areas of the country
I don't believe that this is a bubble at
all I don't see it ending anytime soon